e a virada do ano como é que é a do rico
é bom demais na praia de Copacabana eu
acho interessante que o rico ele não
passa o a virada do ano em casa ele
sempre passa a virada do ano em outro
lugar e no meio da restaurante de folga
a já tá conversando amor próximo ano a
gente podia passar a virada do ano em
Caribe né Opa passa a virada do ano
aonde em casa no mesmo lugar que foi a
Cede de Natal a árvore de natal ainda tá
lá os pisca pisca tá tudo lá e vai ficar
lá até o carnaval a hora que a gente tem
que tirar os enfeites da árvore de natal
e usar como fantasia pro carnaval e a
comida Qual é é a dona ainda Ah mas o
arroz com passas a passas tá com gosto
ruim já era ruim então come é isso e a
carne Qual é de frango que frango o
mesmo do natal e na vira da doando do po
tem champanhe tem champanhe sidra sidra
meu Deus sidra é tão ruim parece o nome
de um monstro da mitologia grega que o
Hércules matou